[Music]
[Applause]
Kendrick Perkins big perk ESPN NBA
analyst and uh won a championship with
the 08 Boston Celtics he's got a new
book Kendrick Perkins shares a different
side of himself powerful experiences
certainly go beyond basketball the
reality of being black in America the
education of Kendrick Perkins a memoir
now available online whoever books are
sold big perk good to talk to you again
uh let me start with Damian Lillard when
as a teammate do you know when somebody
is in the zone
probably after the first 20 points and
they see how efficient he is of
you know but you you could see it you
could see it from the jump and usually
as a guy that played with 11 or 12 Hall
of Famers you could tell when they have
it on their mind you could tell when
it's you know giving them give them the
basketball and get the hell out of the
way that was one of the moments
uh what was the moment that you had
where somebody had that Damian Lillard
night
well you know what I uh I witnessed
Katie go off so many times uh I remember
in the Western Conference finals against
the Spurs I believe it was uh game six I
believe it was he went crazy
um I also win this Paul Pierce to have
those moments as well I remember game
seven 2008 of the semifinals he went
crazy
um and I watched LeBron do the same
thing so it was those times man where it
was just like you know what I saw Kevin
Durant had 40 points and Russell
Westbrook I believe had a 40-point
triple double in the same game you know
and it was just those moments like when
you look and say you know what these are
the reason that these guys get paid the
big bucks
who do you go to beef with still that
you played against
nobody you know what I'm a changed man
since I retired right so it's funny
because you so many guys that I had beef
with on the floor it's like when you
retired you grow up and all of a sudden
you see him it's like man I love playing
against you and you like okay I love
playing against you as well so it's not
even beef I'm gonna tell you this this
is a funny story
Richard Jefferson and I actually hated
each other on the floor hate it and all
of a sudden now since we didn't start
working in the same space for us in the
media and working on shows together
our relationship has grown so close I I
talked to Richard more than I talked to
anybody else I didn't ever played with
or or any of my friends and it's just
weird when you just had a connection
when it's life after basketball when you
finish competing in between those lines
who did you like what was the beef over
we don't even know
it's a crazy club right you don't even
know and I think I think it all stem
from like him and kg and he was just
like you know what I really just don't
like none of those guys and he just had
this beef with me and I could kind of
tell and it was just the feelings were
mutual
why'd the Celtics only win one title
because we wasn't healthy that's the
only reason kg missed 2008 2009 season I
got hurt in 2010 when healthy I started
five never never lost the playoff series
one Health that's the only reason
because of
you know when you look back on what
LeBron is going to mean to the game with
the all-time leading scorer and he's
going to be top five in his set I mean
you know the numbers there perk I've
said before LeBron to me has will have
the greatest career of anybody and I
don't want to get in you know comparing
Mike to LeBron uh you know if I had one
game to win I'd I would take Mike but if
you look at the totality of a career
LeBron's resume is going to be the
greatest resume in in pro basketball
history
well I mean first of all Dan is you know
I'm tired of talking about the goat
conversation to me it's all about your
privilege okay like you know some people
like to drink Hennessy and other people
like the drinks of Rocky at the end of
the day it's still gonna get you feeling
a certain type of way my thing is when
it comes down to LeBron I agree with you
on the greatest career his his career as
his resume is longer than a holiday
weekend I was able to witness okay I was
able to witness since the age of 13
years old playing against him in AAU
playing with him in AAU I was with able
to witness the build up to his greatness
meaning I watched him as a 15 16 year
old go to Media training I watched him
why everybody in between games at AAU
tournaments was eating McDonald's and he
was eating fruit and drinking water so I
watch them get labeled the chosen one I
watched him get called King James and
I'll also say this when it comes down to
pressure pressure is no athlete in
sports history forget just basketball
that was under the pressure of LeBron
James and has exceeded expectations not
one not coming out of high school first
ESPN game you know the build up around
it you know everything and more and he
has succeeded expectations exceeded
expectations and you were there for Pete
Kobe I just love these guys when you see
it in their eyes like man I'm gonna kill
you all right like I'm every possession
what was did you have interaction with
Kobe oh so so many so many and you you
know I it's two it's two it's two uh
instances that I remember there's two
situations one in 2010 game seven I was
on the sideline
and what people have to realize is that
whoever won that whoever won the game in
that series won the rebound in that
battle in game seven I believe Kobe shot
six for 24. but what people don't
realize is that I he had like 15 or 16
rebounds and you could just see that he
had to go into pain and go grab them
boards and he was going to wield his
team to Victory then we had I have
another story you know I was playing in
Oklahoma City and I switched out on Kobe
you know on the pickle road now you know
I clapped my hands and I was like let me
see and he started he hit me you know
with the in and out between the legs
crossing you know in a pull-up jumper
and I almost almost fell and we was
running back down the floor and he was
like all right don't make me tethered up
the ACL
[Laughter]
I like that you were like come on bring
it on like that's the last guy him or
Micah those are the guy and you don't do
that to them no you don't no you don't
you know he was the only guy
that when we went through shoot around
and preparation
it wasn't it wasn't no this is the game
plan for Kobe the game plan for for the
Lakers were let Kobe get his because we
knew he was going to be aggressive and
and counsel everybody else that's the
game plan you played the Lakers with a
Kobe Bryant
uh Kendrick Perkins has a book out it's
a memoir the education of Kendrick
Perkins now available online where her
books are sold also part of ESPN's
Boston Celtics all access this Wednesday
wall-to-wall coverage of the team
followed by the Cavs and Celtics at 7 30
Eastern wait you're not doing this with
the Lakers I thought that it it's
required that you talk about the Lakers
every waking hour Kendrick
perfect
I know right you should hey Dan no lie
you should see me in those but you
should hear me in those production
meetings man I you know it gets to the
point where it gets exhausted okay I
understand that the Lakers actually give
us a reason to talk about them but
I tell them every day not not now maybe
let's start off let's talk about them in
the E topic like we don't have to start
off every show talking about the Lakers
but it feels like you know that they'll
SportsCenter would talk more about the
Lakers comeback against the Mavs than
what Dame did scoring 71 against the
Rockets right yeah but but I will say
this it's just the fate of LeBron James
though Dan that's the thing right like
when LeBron was in Miami we talked about
Miami matter of fact they had an ESPN by
him when Braun was in Cleveland they had
an ESPN clue and I I always say this
right it's a difference they have so so
this is the way that I look at it for
example I look at you you know guys that
have have
done this this whole media space to the
fullest and have been great at it I look
at guys like yourself and Barclay and
Stephen A and you know Scott Van Pelt
and I look at y'all and I say y'all in
the group of you're powerful group and
then they have a popular group right
where you could just see them every now
and then you see guys on there like
myself who just getting started JJ ready
we're popular now but we're not powerful
yet see powerful people moves the needle
and that's when it comes down to
us seeing you know us talk about the
Lakers rather than talk about uh Damien
Lilla because we're basically talking
about LeBron James yeah like if LeBron
James isn't on the Lakers we don't talk
about the Lakers that damn much if Kobe
Bryant isn't on the Lakers we don't talk
about the Lakers that damn much so
that's the difference of actually being
powerful
uh the story that I'm going to take away
from this book the education of Kendrick
Perkins a memoir what's the one story
that you want us taking away from this
you know what then is to one I I will
you know I think every book has a
starting point like and I think that's
the hard part of actually writing a book
in my opinion from learning uh it was
easy for me
um I lost my mind when I was five years
old she was shot and killed by
quote-unquote one of her best friends uh
my dad was in New Zealand never in my
life so I was taken in by my
grandparents my grandmother my
grandfather my grandmother made 40 to 60
dollars a week
as a housekeeper my grandfather made 350
dollars a month uh as the janitor at the
church I grew up in the house that my
great grandfather built with the
siblings was was six five so by the time
I got into the ninth grade I couldn't
fit in the damn house and
I had to go through so much adversity uh
I had to learn and search for security
at times because my grandparents did a
hell of a job I loved them to death but
I was still searching for that security
was just wondering hey if my mom was
living or my dad was in my life how
would things be and so my wife always
tell me now she's like you don't really
show Too Much emotions like we'll go to
a funeral and she don't never see me cry
and always tell her I don't have any
more tears to share because
I've pride myself to sleep so many
nights as a young kid but I also would
like people to take away from
especially see an African-American
Community you get frowned upon uh if you
tell someone or someone that you're
close to or maybe just friends right if
you tell them hey man I'm going to
counseling I need help for my for my
mental you get judged and you get
laughed at so I shared my book about my
experience when I was with the Oklahoma
City Thunder in the off season while I
went down to Lawrence Kansas and I went
to anger management for a month and a
half and I was in a classroom from eight
to five in the evening with these
high-powered doctors uh that was also in
there with me as well from you know
getting in trouble and they respect the
fields uh you know abusing their power
so I'm in there with anesthesiologists
spinal surgeons you name it and I've
learned so much being there for us just
learning how to you know let things go
learning how to not put myself in
certain positions learn learning how to
fast forward and think about should I go
to certain things or should I just stay
home so that I could kind of you know
not say foresee the future but actually
put myself in the right position and so
I share that story one because it's one
it's my journey but I also shared to let
people know that it's okay to go out
there and seek help to protect your
Mentor so if you having a problem like
go sit down and talk with somebody like
it's crucial so those are the two
messages and the messages was how my
upbringing is like so many people stop
when they hit adversity well I've
learned I got to figure things out and I
figured things out on the Fly I don't
let it stop me in my tracks
good to talk to you perk glad you're
doing well thank you and good luck with
the book Dave thanks for having me on I
appreciate you legend that is Kendrick
Perkins the book is the education of
Kendrick Perkins a memoir now available
online whoever books are sold also part
of ESPN's Boston Celtics all access
that'll be Wednesday wall-to-ball
coverage of the team followed by Kev
Celtics 7 30 Eastern